so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up guys this is the dope as usual
podcast I am Thomas dopasiola whatever
you want to call me I'm here literally
right next to Marty O'Neill what's up
folks uh this is a different episode
okay we have two special guests
officially more on the podcast more than
anyone whatever
Jake Josh Wolf thank you guys for being
here once again thank you so much for
having us now Mushroom City already
started I'm just gonna point it out now
in case you yeah spacing out yeah Josh
is eating a lot of mushrooms I'm
probably on a gram Marty I had a little
half a little chew over here no I'm
driving I'm driving I'm driving so yeah
I'm not driving I'm flying so all right
so we're gonna be good
um I'm gonna I'm gonna oh yeah I'm gonna
highlight Josh's [ __ ] jacket real
quick oh um he got it from Matthew
McConaughey but now the question we were
talking about earlier what came first
the drugs or the jacket and it's a good
question yeah it's a good question it's
a good question I I don't disagree yeah
yeah it truly is a good joke it's a good
question and
you definitely sell drugs I mean I I
definitely do them yeah
I mean if I'm wearing this I definitely
do that at a Ross or a clothing store I
got this at a gas station yeah in New
Mexico uh I also got a bow and arrow
there why I
got a grinder I got some some ceramic
plates I got a poncho and another son
yeah yeah an extra one and a whole other
life they actually they had like stuffed
like squirrels and [ __ ] yeah I didn't
want to buy any I just didn't I was like
I don't want to fly I don't want to fly
with it it was an option yeah but the
thing the thing is like I just don't
know for you it was an option like I
might purchase this oh yeah definitely
yeah 100 that's right I was driving I
would have bought it but because I knew
I had to fly home you didn't have to
deal with the TSA yo I just didn't want
to put it through my check-in when I was
walking on the [ __ ] plane they were
like is that a squirrel yeah about it
last thing you want tripping balls is
the head of a dead animal I didn't even
think about that yeah I I thought you
were going to buy it to like screw with
Mom and like just random she would have
hated it that's the only reason I know
but just like randomly put it somewhere
and just like wait and see how long it
takes for her to notice it I love doing
stuff like that man I love I you know
Beth and I part of our relationship is
it's like a she's dies a thousand paper
cuts a day do you know what I mean
yeah
it's like it's like is that enough to
get not enough for you to get mad at but
after the 100th one you're like a [ __ ]
do you know what I mean does she dab on
the mushrooms with you ever no no God no
she's the same one at the house dude
yeah and also like even the couple times
that she's tried smoking weed and just
like just taking a hit off of anything
it's bad newspaper I don't think I've
ever asked where's she from she's from
Louisiana
yeah and so but the drugs that's not her
thing at the one time listen the one
time the [ __ ] she end up with you dude
what time is happening so the one time
uh she was like I'm gonna eat some
edibles I'm like okay I said but I was
doing a like an evening radio show like
I'm gonna be gone she was like I'm fine
because she had had a little bit before
so she texted me she's like yeah I just
took a little more because I had so much
fun the last time and I go how much more
she goes I just doubled it and I was
like
I get a phone call you usually have to
come home right now why I think I lost
my teeth oh okay so I come home there's
vomit on the ground oh God and and I'm
like what's going on she goes I threw up
my teeth that does my teeth I need you
to tell me are those my teeth and of
course I was like yeah those are your
teeth stop
I wanted to I paused for a second I'm
like is the joke worth it no no no no it
was so if it had been anyone besides her
it would have been me dude I 100 would
have done it to you who are you kidding
yeah of course for sure but anyone
besides because she's the sweetest
person to do drugs right yeah right you
wanted a hate drugs that's right yeah
but you would think after that someone
would learn their lesson I think we did
it a couple more times I don't think she
did teeth a couple more times but she
definitely because she didn't with you
but she did with me when you were out of
town oh yeah that's a bummer yeah I had
not not that intensive situations but
you know similar realize the second time
around like you know what the third or
the fourth or the fifth she couldn't
have done it that much she I think she
looks at us and she's like you look like
you're having so much fun yeah I am and
it's just not for her yeah that's all
it's just not for her
if I woke up like drugs aren't for me oh
dude I would end it no
no
no
no
serious
not that serious I I
if they ever started to impede on either
my happiness my peace or how I went
about my daily life I would stop them
the next day yeah and the next
if they if I ever thought oh I'm not oh
you're talking about drugs I thought you
meant if someone was gonna stop your
happiness
you're like yeah stop them too yeah
I'm sorry
both but both are right yes yes same
same song I'm trying to decide if I
should eat what minute are we at should
I eat more of course wait wait wait what
is wait so what is what have you already
had I'll this I'll probably be see ing
the first time we met dude I was
probably around 2.5 2.7 about to be
right about there that's right so what
are you at right now though I went for
it I wouldn't I'm not encouraging you to
be there too I'm saying like over the
course of this time yes I might me too
are you at are you at 1.5 right now I
think yes I don't think yeah [ __ ] it you
might as well take take one of the
gummies get to two you might as well get
to two or three the caramel is delicious
these are grams yeah I ate one of those
yeah all right so I'm like I'm at the
back of the shrooms has evolved on the
show two grams episode number two this
one yeah yeah the first time what was
the last time where's the shrooms I
thought you had them oh dude oh yeah and
one and then the first time by the way
it's when I knew how how much of a g you
were because I was floating in some sort
of outer space
and you were like how good is that oh my
God yeah that just tastes like candy how
good is that I thought I was gonna have
to dude dude how oh it's like a Tootsie
Roll good or is that yeah I can't wait
to try that I want to try it this
weekend dude it's so delicious the dude
who makes them is the I I should have
asked him if I could have said his name
that's really dangerously good yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and that's why like and
there's something about the caramel in
particular
that hit super quickly
oh how is digesting your body I don't
know [ __ ] but you get high yeah he said
oh [ __ ] it's the whole recipe too good
to just it doesn't taste like shrooms at
all eat it yeah I mean it tastes better
than those mushrooms over on that table
for sure you bought three varieties of
mushrooms today not strings ways of
eating yes oh and three different
strains oh this is these are penis envy
oh these are small yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah the penis envy ones are here
they're so delicious those are so good
yeah
you can melt this in a drink dude you
don't it's not even like when you when I
say caramel you think you're gonna have
to you're gonna lose a tooth yeah yeah
in The Chew it's like butter it
dissolves in your mouth
it is
top of the line it's like a better
Tootsie Roll kind of like it's like a
Tootsie Roll texture Tootsie Rolls wish
that they were yeah
okay okay okay fast [ __ ] Eric Estrada
wave hair going in my eye for the past
couple days bugging me oh you guys got
your [ __ ] situated with the hats and
you're gonna get two and one head back
oh
bro just a crazy headband moment would
be nice Hulk Hogan I'm just gonna start
rocking the Hulk
I have to just get some quick silks
quick silks on the head a [ __ ] I
would I don't mind a headband right now
it's just a headband that says Yola oh
that's a cocaine dealership
oh my God
I love the name but I really went the
wrong direction when I picked that
[ __ ]
for what I do definitely doesn't work
I I gotta tell you man yeah I can
definitely feel the for me I can already
feel that I'm also double your weight so
you ate them before the show this time
usually me too though so I haven't felt
him yeah I can I'm definitely starting
to get hi I I but I've also I'm also
probably a little lighter than I am
normally being because you're [ __ ]
shredded right now I am what's your name
your next special was it awkwardly
awkwardly ripped and pale
it's a good title it's a great shot of
the [ __ ] great it's a pretty good
awkward really awkwardly
anyway I'm watching that show yeah I
mean because I mean if we're talking
past oh my [ __ ] God I thought that
was your skin
yeah yeah no this is this is my this is
the color of my skin damn it matches the
Jade yeah
she said crispy
yeah my legs are not that white I can
actually take it I just want to let
everybody know camera One camera two
yeah
that camera was like [ __ ] this I'm out
yeah
I think you went like camouflage into
the white wall behind you this is pretty
bad the color of my skin on my leg is
like what you find at the bottom of the
ocean where you're like that hump
[ __ ] yeah dude he looked like the marble
man up top and some dead dude on the
bottom vampire yeah yeah vampire Vampiro
yeah strong vampire
there you go working out six days a week
working out at the hotel [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah for like 30 years 100 for like 30
straight years yeah a hundred from
College on to your I know exactly 22
years old to now so 31 years 31 years I
was that was body weight stuff weights
whatever I could do I could see you
being like a Kung Fu [ __ ] black like
quietly
punched through someone's chest
but you know I'm no blackball
he's definitely not the martial arts one
I am now this dude was a black belt by
the time when he was 10 years old yeah
oh no [ __ ] yeah and Taekwondo I don't
know he used to be able to kick [ __ ] off
of the top of my head thing yeah that's
height yeah he's taller than me at 10.
yeah oh he was definitely a small
offense and like when when he hit six
foot I'm like you're not 100 pounds yet
but congratulations that you're six feet
six foot I had six foot my freshman at
the end of my freshman year in high
school I went in at five nine and then
when I graduated uh by the time summer
had started I was around six one so like
I get like a Crazy Kitchen yes
crazy gross for a fellas no oh you I
just kind of rolled that off I knew that
was just all caps so I was like
fully yeah yeah I mean yeah
go get me my heels go get me my heels
don't give me my inputs
um
uh but I was and then I was a black belt
and Krav Maga by the time I was I don't
think you were ever black Belden Krav
Maga what is that
is that I was
I love that we're having two separate
conversations right now it's a heavy but
but it's not Jewish
I need you guys to explain Israelis it's
an Israeli uh
but it's what they train their military
with yes dude Israelis yes Jewish people
yeah
you're right I'm gonna give you that one
I'm gonna give you that one Jewish boxer
uh
it's an Israeli form of self-defense
teach you how to like well they can
teach you how to like disarm people so
if someone has like a knife to you or a
gun to you so it's like by the way
um that would be my rap name ipso facto
not a bad one actually that's my best
one I think yeah that's your best one
yeah I think last year this year if so
facto you're a rapper this year that's
right
DJ yamaka
I like that the dreidel kid Jazzy Jew
yeah DJ Jazzy Jew DJ Jazzy Jew yeah I
like how happy Hanukkah oh my God
[Laughter]
that was [ __ ] awesome what's up by
the way I'm Jewish I'm for sure hi
I'm not yet how long we got can I smoke
weed here yeah can you go back to that
does it say West Side gun sound yeah of
course this is on your [ __ ] wait can I
hear it oh we got a whole sound bank I
mean I know that's hairstyle
that's just a rapper that's his ad-libs
what's going on
[Music]
I mean I usually am and I got into a
habit of it in the last couple years
especially when I moved out to my own
place
um and knowing that I didn't have to
worry about anybody else smelling what
my place smelled like with backwards in
it I just started doing it
um I go on like phases I'm usually a
glass guy like I usually long ribs the
easiest way to do it like I've had a
roller since I was 18 and then I just
always had
um but then I just got into this phase
and I haven't found my way out of it yet
um you will eventually the winter cough
and hack and when she gets somewhere
cold and you're smoking blunts yeah I
smoke only but real quick most elegant
man ever right now look at them
not gonna lie it's the best lit the best
joint he's ever lived
usually yeah usually he's like lit the
crutch and I don't even know how you do
that look I don't even know what the
[ __ ] going on like part of it's lit
and then there's just a whole
I tell you all I'm thinking this entire
time how high you were
yeah I could see it on your face the
wrong thing it is I hope they enjoy
talking because I'm so hot I'm glad you
didn't do the full other caramel I think
sticking it too is gonna be good no yeah
this was a wise move yeah you'll be on
Earth with us yeah well tradition
I'm very well aware I drove him that
first time I've been here every time
reasons that I love hanging out with you
is because I know I can get super [ __ ]
up and you won't get molested yeah
exactly right I'm not gonna leave you
out in the desert again
dude you oh what thank God you didn't
leave me out there good Lord thank you
dropping me off dropping him off at my
softball game where he's thinking about
my girlfriend for the first time I think
about that a lot he was yeah because I I
haven't been with something next to
somebody when I'm not [ __ ] up in so
long that I saw your eyes I'm like
doesn't even know his name right now
let's just let him be I saw you staring
at the window for about 30 minutes and
went he'll come back and then you said I
just came back to Earth
I looked at Rosie in the room you went
like that
yeah dude bro it was the first time you
met Iman then that's the first time he
met my girlfriend we talked about this
last time and we did and I'll tell you
something because we can't remember this
one of the reasons
since the first night dude I met you
that I feel I feel Comfort you're one of
the very few people in the world that
are that I allow myself to get a little
like I was not in control of me oh for
sure I didn't know I spotted and that's
like oh you need help but that but but
you're one of the very few people in the
world that I will allow myself to be
like that in front of because I trust
you dude I'm gonna wear that day 100
trust you you ever seen the Mexican uh
cars where they paint and it's like the
guy holding the lady yeah that's me and
you yeah don't worry I got you don't
worry where's tether to Earth yeah
that's right yeah there you go I'm the
anchor so you don't fly away when you
said tethered I was like you mean from
that movie us I haven't seen that one
yet I haven't seen another am I the only
one who's seen us did you saw it yeah
did you see nope did you see his new one
can I be honest
didn't like it nope not like I'll go I
go six and a half seven out of ten like
for me there was just some
inconsistencies that I just didn't enjoy
and they were too obvious I agree with
you he gets such a huge pass from me I
thought it was great because of this I
had never seen Jaws mixed with a Malian
movie in my life all right and I was
like yo I feel like there's a shark
hunting people and I'm [ __ ] scared
for these people that and the fact that
they did an entire house that scene I'm
not gonna ruin everybody that scene
it's about aliens [ __ ] sorry
cameras uh the scene where everything's
raining down yeah you thought of this
wrote it out yeah the day before I know
you were Jew he's comedian [ __ ] mad
tv like this is a [ __ ] comedian I've
been watching a long time now he's
coming up like this is gonna be mine
this is what I'm saying is that it
doesn't matter what he gets a pass for
me
because
is look man doesn't get enough credit uh
what's the dude's name uh Childish
Gambino right oh Donald Glover he's
great he's towning obviously but think
about what this dude is doing all of the
genres of acting which you're gonna
count comedy and key and peel was not
funny real dude everybody still calls
him Aaron my friend Aaron I only call
him everybody says the same the only
it's the only time I call anybody a
different name or like Denise like d
nice like anything yeah
like
it's incredible but same with Donald
Glover like he's done every range of
acting and also Top 100 Billboard music
like The Dude I didn't know about him
before I heard the music I'm like this
is hard yeah I didn't know who it was I
didn't know who Donald Glover was until
either who game you know it was oh you
see it was the other way for me yeah and
I it was like I basically confused this
whole time
no but what does he help write it was
the other show Parks and Rec or 30 Rock
oh yeah yeah yeah one of those one of
those shows yeah yeah he was wait hold
on he was a writer on one of those yeah
yeah he's uh I didn't know that I get a
diverse [ __ ] by the way I get
those two shows mixed up too I only
watch the office
because the other ones might so off as
light
I'm gonna wait office light that's
weight what's the new show you were
saying you're working on
um I'm working on something I don't know
if I'm allowed to say what it is but
it's something that's going to be
allegedly it's gonna be something uh I
think prank related which is pretty cool
uh your genre yeah something fun to be
in
um I already told I told the art
director day one because uh he's part of
a pretty well-known group
um I was like you can't get me he's like
that's what everyone says he's like
that's what Bernie Mac said and I go and
look what happened and I was like well
yeah that might have been a little fog
but hey you never got God yeah I will
take that one yeah it's fast but tell
them about our show dude oh dude
tomorrow I mean I would but I think I'm
too hot yeah I'll try should I try
in a world
where Josh and Jacob Wolfe oh it stopped
these are all gonna happen
will you stop that what do you stop okay
I thought it was a pre-recorded thing
and then I was like how'd you get
Jacob's voice and then I was like oh
all right all right that's cool the
disassociation started yeah to
disconnect he's going to be thinking
about a 12 years that's super cool oh
his voice whoa he's here
yeah Drake's quick yeah he went right
into it I was ready you're gonna get it
um okay so we are with the are you gonna
do the I'll just do a regular I don't
think it was I think the moment has
passed
um so we filmed hey Take the Wheel Take
the Wheel yeah I'm trying to but uh I
need you to just shut
it down for a second shut it down yeah
um so we filmed this awesome
um like 9 10 episode thing uh it's a
competition show that we filmed and it's
just me and my dad
um doing stupid competitions and then
making the other one do a stupid
punishment
um yeah whoever loses whoever loses the
winner gets to pick the punishment and
now you guys saw episode one first
episode which premieres tomorrow on my
YouTube channel at 8pm Eastern 8 P.M
okay so but this comes out Monday so
guys already go to just discuss Josh
Wolf yeah it's Josh Wolf comedy Joshua
so this comes out Monday perfect so
listen dude you saw it I saw a lot of
things
and and tell everybody don't tell
everybody what the show was but let me
ask you a question was it entertaining
I'd watch it on TV anyway yeah right
that's it yeah
if this was Spike TV it'd be a new show
there's nowhere near me I'm watching
this I'm watching this
they probably wouldn't show that um oh
yeah they would at first I was like Wow
remember we were like 12 I killed the
ranch they would definitely show this on
Spike TV 100 now this is uh this is
normal
uh I mean look man
it wasn't so normal for me does every
episode yeah that's some point it every
episode does not
end up with my [ __ ] naked okay no so
we can say it I'll say yeah um
until your ass came out yeah yeah and
that is literally seeing to your body
yeah
I mean besides the mouth you don't see
into people's bodies often yeah yeah I
know uh how do you think how do you
think I felt he
were on the on the that's not how the
body works yeah camera One camera two
that's not how that works I mean I just
uh just in case anybody was curious
that's nice that's not how it works I'm
high but I'm not that high not yet but
dude
the the best part of that punishment
was where Jacob and Jonathan my brother
had to had to be because I hired him to
be set producer that day
so like like forcing them into positions
well yeah that was the only this room
was so small they just had to stand
there by the way said photographer not
set producer which makes it even worse
yeah yeah yeah yeah because he's got to
be he has to yeah he can't be anywhere
else he sent me a picture
okay so he sent me a picture of my
[ __ ] right and but a close-up
and then he just said
guess what this is
and it enough time had passed like I
had no idea I was like I don't I don't
know dude what it what is that he said
you have a mole like what are you sick
what's wrong with you he was like that's
your [ __ ] dude I was like oh never
seen it sir
never looked but thank you he was like
that's what it looks like just so you
know I was right up on it so
congratulations we got posters up on
comedian Josh wolf.com
I had my hands up like this I pretended
I was reading a book the whole time
because I like wanted to see his facial
reactions but I didn't want to see uh
what was going down you know what I'm
saying I was like yeah you know what he
was like what are you doing I was like
reading a book it's just sitting here
looking at my hands like oh wait while
you were filming oh yeah well I mean
while we were while we were doing what
you know that you know that activity
didn't make more sense when people see
this [ __ ] yeah yeah I I it's hard to
explain it but like I just know I looked
like this and just know I was
metaphor by the way the episode is more
than just the punishment oh a hundred
percent however funny the funny is in
the episode the Absurd is at the end
like yeah
that's right there's funny in the
episode and it's not just you and him
there's like other there's a lot we've
guessed it we have a lot of moving Parts
name for the show not one of us has said
it family Tesla
it comes out tomorrow
now first let me ask a question this is
um no but you're getting the waves and I
got them yeah no not waves it's almost
like it's on rollers but it's just not
it has yeah just
it's just your jacket it's just a
movement the best gas station jacket
you've got the best weed and the worst
cocaine with that jacket oh yeah yeah
but you know what I got the best stories
oh for sure
Dude any topic that comes up he's like
oh tadpoles I got a story for you you're
like what
tadpoles what does that even mean yeah
tadposers are baby frogs Yeah I know
what tadpoles are
you ass that's comedic genius right
there
there are baby frogs
I'm very well aware of what to add
posters I found out what tadpoles were I
was in the [ __ ] Bear Creek in Merced
and I was like yo what the [ __ ] are
these things it shocked me and then I
learned about it in second grade at
school yeah because they don't look like
they should be those things grow legs
this don't make sense yeah babies come
out with legs and arms I was a child I
only got there's the information yeah
facts yeah I don't like it I don't like
it I don't like it either but I can't
explain it you know what I'm saying
speaking of comedic genius you guys are
traveling the world oh yeah yeah we're
good we will be yeah it's gonna be
[ __ ] awesome Australia and New
Zealand are we legal Engineers
no oh very very much not illegal in
Australia very very much illegal oh the
place yeah I didn't realize I have
friends there these guys are illegal
I don't know
let me tell you something I am going to
be as high as I think I can manage on a
16-hour flight hoping that I thought is
it I think it's 18. it might be one of
the two hoping that some of it just
hangs on by the time I get there are you
gonna get one of the cool pod floods
with the purple lighting and [ __ ]
I probably will he's not no I'm probably
sitting close
[Laughter]
yep that's the unfortunate
but the answer to that question on this
side of the table is yeah
look at the jacket uh tell me where I'm
sitting yeah
you want me to you want the truth tell
me where you're sitting you're sitting
with the bats in this in this coach
if you show up at an airport in this
ridiculous jacket
you're getting the second screening do
you think so oh [ __ ] yeah bro okay
I'm gonna tell you something right now
oh okay I did you just did you oh it was
TSA
Jesus they wish they could carry guns
some of them do they're not stable
enough for guns are we serious I was
gonna load up vicious attack dog for
this episode I didn't I'm sorry let me
tell you something I think it's the
opposite I think this dude breezes
through
I people I think people think
he must be important
to wear that [ __ ] depends what kind
of pants and shoes you have on what
state are you in yeah um
Alabama
you're a normal guy you're a regular
father in Alabama I think Oh I thought
you meant how high I was no trouble with
this jacket depends on what state you're
in like oh what state yeah
this he's a movie star yeah yeah dude
right now
in Missouri Dolly Parton's son debates
exactly what I would tell people like
that's my mom I'm Dolly Parton's son and
I'd be like oh okay I could say that
because there's no I was gonna argue
no what a great you know what what a
crap oh my God in Tennessee you should
have rode that [ __ ] for [ __ ] ever
yo nobody would ever question that I
gotta pick local people how come you
don't have her last name
I'm a comedian I want to write off her
coattails and I'm doing my own thing oh
my mom's calling sorry
[Laughter]
you missed Tennessee for like two years
yo
dude's son
yeah I know that's one thing because
somebody could Google that now
you know that's in front of you you're
convincing enough yeah you ever met
somebody
who could convince you oh for sure
nobody's gonna even [ __ ] question it
this guy
to a stranger to a stranger yeah like
Matthew McConaughey is my dad I mean my
my brother he's older than me you could
be like he's my uncle okay yeah and like
with that jacket like [ __ ] yeah Daisy
confused it was supposed to be me
no doubt about it I think yeah we've
conquered this one yeah
um so wait you go to Australia where the
weeds illegal
yeah for like three weeks
two weeks three weeks hello shows
yo dude lots of lots of planes one city
one city already sold out in January
damn God damn for everyone out there hit
this [ __ ] October
well done crazy [ __ ] awesome yo I'm
telling you how humbling it is it's so
[ __ ] humbling we were talking about
this earlier yo the amount of people I
know who's on my list of people that I
would just leave my house to go see
so the fact that I'm on anyone's list is
the most humbling thing to me I think
about that every time I step on stage
I'm honest with you I it doesn't matter
how many people I think you left your
house to come see me
that's so humbling to me and so like it
I I people you ask even the small
if if it's a smaller crowd I maybe
perform harder
you are you don't deserve a lesser show
just because less of you showed up
that's not yours thank God you guys are
here yeah that's not yours that [ __ ]
fault
if anything that's my problem but yeah
dude now how much have you been on the
road with them because you're working
[ __ ] TV shows and [ __ ] but you're on
the road hobby too um I think I've been
on the road uh more consistently I think
than I've ever been yeah in recent years
um but with me working I am usually
booked so but starting starting next
year but starting in January uh so this
will be my last show that I'll work on
right now so starting in January I'll be
on the road every weekend with him
select weekend's like a birthday or
whatnot but like every weekend yeah
we'll [ __ ] figure it out yeah
you watched that tone with me dude I
love having him on the road with me
and
yeah yeah and his older brother
was just with me in Dallas and and his
older brother like he and I will do Q
A's and have a good time
because people like asking questions
about that I saw a video older brother
of spills Family secret and then click
on the thoughts tell them about it
that's a good one
um so it turns out that you see you know
you guys know the whole porn joke with
like yeah my grandparents shut the [ __ ]
up we got a lot of fan questions follow
up about that so so it turns out that
while everyone was out of the house
because my brother had also visited he
was about before he deployed Afghanistan
for the first time
so my brother
came to the house and his last couple
days there he decided to order the porn
and knowing that the blame would fall on
me because when everybody left the house
sad it was just me and my grandparents
here's the reason why
on the Wikipedia page this is even worse
like growing up my uh he called him one
day and he goes hey did you know that on
your Wikipedia page it only says you
have one kid
and he was like what and how he was on
speaker and I was like
what what did you say and he said yeah
he says it's just he says it just says
that you have one kid and your only kid
is Jacob
and I was like that's pretty funny like
that's obviously not true he's got two
more kids but that makes me laugh
when I asked him I'm like crazy right I
go
crazy the the Wikipedia page just I just
have one kid and he goes yeah crazy
and so if we find out I find out later
that anybody can edit yeah
you know how many times
I would let him put the other kids on
for like a week or so and he would check
just to make sure and then after like a
week of false hope I would take it off
this dude would just take him off
he would take like a couple weeks later
just to be sure and he'd be like what
the [ __ ] who keeps removing these and
but but you know I don't know
I think that's dead about technology but
that's a Thousand Cuts right here yeah
hey come on Jake wasn't lying
dude it would do by the way it was super
fun he went on stage for the first time
when we were with him in San Antonio and
he's told that on stage and I ran out
from the back and I was like what the
[ __ ] is going on here
I was like how have I still been playing
into this this whole time knowing it
still wasn't me
and it's been you for over a decade the
whole time like dude that's such a long
joke in the making I don't think y'all
understand
almost 10. you know your world knows
about that yeah but by the way hold on
to it
until the best until the best moment
like good first time on stage just in
front of a packed house and he just
ripped that to start and he was like Hey
I just want to confess to something whoa
because he just started and I was like
dude I think what must have happened is
this right
he probably was going to say something
but then just was enjoying like as
somebody who pulls pranks
not being blamed it's funny and watching
other people fight about it is the best
it's the best it's like oh okay so what
we hope for is a reaction
if you pull pranks you know that
reaction is if you don't react you're
not gonna get a prank pulled on you
because no that's not what we're hearing
yes right and and I need to feel it no
pending family members against each
other
it's porn is just but also involving the
grandparents also it's like
generational I think the craziest
here's what I think
here's what I think here's what I think
for months you're lesser
here's what I think what I think is I
think he was just trying to get you
blamed for something I don't think he
thought ahead that the grandparents are
going to be involved right I think he
was just trying to get you blamed for
ordering two hundred dollars
so much porn yeah we went to Afghanistan
after yeah you mean to like the military
yeah these are two terms so it's erased
he served the country you you have to
take the blame so and this is like [ __ ]
it yeah yeah basic training and takes it
was awkwardly blamed Next Level so but
by the way and and so I think if it just
been me blaming you if the if the
grandparents hadn't been involved I
think he'd a Champion Way earlier oh for
sure yeah it was better to watch it but
also what it became it just like he you
can't jump in on it you've got to let
that play out like it's it's something
we get asked every time my mom asked me
yeah it's like for real
watches all you guys [ __ ] it's like uh
Is that real did he do that way Mom I
mean I asked him after he said it wasn't
him and I believe him
I'm telling you like I for real I
thought honestly I still wanted to stick
with my theory of that it was Grandpa
you know like really one 40 years in the
making so glad
yeah well I mean like you also I don't
know what the best
but yeah look in reality just actually
defending himself yeah yeah well look
and also you know he offered me money to
just say be like hey look even if you
didn't do it and he was like he was like
I'll pay the porn bill and I'll give you
200 that's theoretically 400 just look
at me right now and say you did it even
if you didn't I might have done that by
the way if I were you oh yeah but here's
the best part when I found out when you
said that I was like oh he's desperate
now because you're in your head oh I was
and so I was like nah Grandma Grandpa
and I was like and that was that was
like my villain origin story and I was
like this is the come up bro and I was
like ah this is gonna run it I'm gonna
run this for years because I'm telling
the truth and I know for sure this is
your Marvel origin story that's my
ability
oh I'm pretty hot that was a good uh
that was a good one
I I'd like
tell me what you're feeling right now
from that delicious character I forgot
what we were filming I was just talking
and listening
that's when I know like oh no
stay up late
Still Point [ __ ] we're on point right
now yeah we're doing great I'm talking
to myself
I was talking to you guys stay on point
you as soon as I remembered like oh
we're filming yeah yeah that's right
that's when I realized like uh [ __ ] they
hit me because it was like three minutes
ago I was listening to your story about
the poor thing I'm like damn this thing
did not hit me at all that was a major
topic on the [ __ ] show I will tell
you something
for real like it when he did that live
it was
I have to tell you it was exactly how it
should have been done like I'm so glad
that's how it happened here just one yo
but he
no
he did it the exact right way and then
just sat down like he had been doing it
for 10 years just [ __ ] sad
so calm this dude he didn't trip over
words like he looked like he had been
doing it for a long time yeah I wonder
what other [ __ ] he has going on you guys
are almost as if somebody it was
somebody who'd been to actual war and
since seen
worse things than a crowd yeah yeah
almost like that that it's exactly what
how it was described back to me when I
was like you weren't nervous he was like
no
and then he was basically said something
but I paraphrased what he said and I was
like got it yeah why would you be
I mean I guess that's fair I don't
really hear that but yeah yeah no no no
it was very he was like yeah he was like
fun yeah no you get to let that ride in
life yeah dude yeah he was like this is
fun oh damn it these are stronger than I
thought they were yeah the mushrooms
[ __ ] yeah we're pretty hot
oh I'm good I just uh I mean they're
they're deliciously strong
and that's I think that that joint is
going to take you to the yeah this joint
is water essentially one of my mushrooms
really does nothing too does nothing
I think it's just to take my mind off
the fact that I'm super high on
mushrooms
um now these uh
got me like right here yeah I feel like
this and they happen
the caramel happens so quickly it
happened like that I swear to God I was
fine then two seconds what the [ __ ] it
happens it happens so quickly you were
here like that was delicious now I'm
high yeah
you know what I mean wow that tastes so
much better than I I'm high right now
I'm at like two and a half
and I think I should just stop and I'm
going to you're good at two or two
you're in two I don't know you're good
at two I'm good right where I am right
now except they're delicious
yeah like I like the the
um the gummy
I would have another one
what time is it I would say it's almost
set stop right it's almost time I would
have another one I
I got a question so hit me another
YouTube title that we saw were browsing
around here that has to do with your
brother
the day my brother stopped farting in my
mouth yeah which sounds
I I'd say this and that that is an
actual day
I like these mushrooms yeah listen dude
you know sometimes the lesson was
sometimes life's gonna fart in your
mouth what the [ __ ] what you gonna do
what you gonna do about it turn your
head yo what you gonna do about it
and I know what I did
is your older brother yeah okay which
way which brother there was not a lot
for me to do
I asked my dad I go hey
dude
[Laughter]
and my son was like
what do you want me to do about it and
I'm like that's a great question like
while you're sleeping or what am I
talking about no he's they were bigger
than me when I was asleep so all three
of them
it would be like uh at first there was a
little bit of a beat down this Andy
dufresne's story yeah yeah it's not just
I don't just I'm not just like hey he's
not like Andy defard I'm like cool yeah
you know what I mean like
these mushrooms took me completely off
my shed they smacked me in the [ __ ]
face
Marty's not on mushrooms neither of you
you can keep us on point yeah we're
getting farted on your little apple bar
I mean listen
why would they go hey my little brother
and my fart inside of his mouth did you
just close your lips well then you know
it look man this is what you decide
how many punches equals an open mouth oh
got you oh you don't know do you know
what I'm saying like
some people they're bigger than you
yeah sometimes sometimes sometimes life
farts in your mouth man and then years
later he has to tape your ass and film
it and then you should have farted in
his face
oh different brother okay all right all
right I'm glad I didn't grow up in that
generation yo you guys like
feel the fires and [ __ ] right yeah No
One's Gonna fart my mouth and compare it
to a fire
but you guys listen you guys lit fires
and [ __ ] right yeah okay so like
take that
and then being like how can I light a
fire
in my own house
okay on my brother
take that same anger take that same
angle that energy keep that fire energy
or how does that how does that end up on
this dude without it you made sense out
of it without it leaving a mark do you
know what I mean I don't want to hurt
him
you said you're getting beat down it's
like a but that's the thing
he would just say take the [ __ ]
oh it's an option yeah oh I gotcha okay
it's an option it's an option the
punches are an option dude that's it he
would tell you straight up these punches
are your options sounds like some Joey
sounds like a gang dude just one big
bigger dude when you were a small person
like all it takes is you to be six seven
years old
see you know what I'm saying
all right tripping no I heard that too
oh God I thought it was [ __ ] just me
nobody reacted that would be amazing if
it was just you I can still hear it
she has some technical difficulties
going on these mushrooms are [ __ ] up
my ass now tell me some are they visual
for you no I just feel like I'm on a
boat
yes when I when the table it's like he
was doing this [ __ ] a minute ago but
it's totally not [ __ ] moving I know
that right right no I had to touch it to
make sure that I definitely um
understand
why you were feeling the way you were
I feel so [ __ ] off
got some fan questions here you mean
mushroom wise yeah
this guy I haven't felt like I'm about
to start
oh [ __ ] in a long time the last time we
chilled I was yeah even the first
mushroom episode
this is way more intense well this is
like they're just they're completely
different
do you know what I mean it's been a
while and and these ones aren't super
visual for me not at all but they're
real like I feel it like
oh yeah finally for sure for sure and
like super for me super present and
giggly and I can't wait to try them I'm
super excited whoa these caramel things
are are there are mushrooms like
lightweight to you now that you [ __ ]
with other [ __ ]
um I I really only [ __ ] with like uh
mushrooms and acid like though that's
like the furthest I'll go and I really
know and I haven't done anything further
than that because it's just not really
my cup of tea you know what I'm saying
um but it depends on the mushroom you
know what I'm saying like I've had bad
acid
um but I've never really had bad
mushrooms
so only bad mushrooms are when they
don't work I feel but I've never had
that I've had acid that has never hit
and I've had a bad trip on acid but I've
never had a bad trip on mushrooms or
I've never not tripped or or at least
had something on mushrooms was it a
fully badass a trip or did it just go
into it and then come back it it started
out before we even dropped with some
like paranoia and then that just like we
were like all right we think we're good
and then it just like started out fine
and then the paranoia like certain
events had come up that like furthered
the paranoia and then it just spiraled
we're kind of paranoid uh just a bunch
of like like stuff like uh I don't even
know it was like uh cops are coming no
no it was like
I think it was like something about like
a friend
who was like we thought was like using
us or something like that so it just
became like oh really do you have that
kind of paranoia oh that's just what I
think of no are you paranoia yeah but it
was like yeah so it was like something
weird that's never been a paranoia for
my I wonder if that is for other people
uh 100 100 cops are coming
I mean there are some yeah I I just
thought about that right now right yeah
dude how crazy
the fact that where my life has been
that that's never been
a paranoia thank God
oh yeah it's definitely been until
recently actually this is a [ __ ] what a
crazy
yeah that's scary especially if you're
like smoking weed you're already
paranoid yeah in [ __ ] the east coast
and you're like cops might be coming
because the neighbors might have called
them I gotta tell you I've never
it's never never I don't know why I mean
I got semi-arrested at LSU for smoking
weed
yeah I mean I
I guess I've never been
I
know you get the time for smoking weed
your dad shows up like this all
mushrooms yeah facts about your parents
he's too [ __ ] up to drive yeah I was
out
I was in Louisiana though as well so
like I was like like when I was like got
detained like legitimately got detained
yeah um and I was with two other guys
and I was like it's not damaged mine
because it was re-driving no no we were
um in in the in the LSU cops defense we
were smoking on campus oh like outside
so like granted my fault but also I had
been there multiple times
um and been fine too but I should have
uh I should have been in my usual spot
that I had no one ever saw me at you
never spent a night in jail though right
nope okay
got out of that one what well I mean
like the when I got handcuffed by the oh
yeah I got I got out of the handcuffs it
was like two weeks before winter break
and I was coming back like I I was like
done with college and I decided to move
back to LA so I was two weeks from going
home and I was like listen man like hey
hey hey
okay cool yeah yeah sure
nip it yeah yeah yeah
you got out of jail stop that's a good
point
and you stop like what what's going on
yeah facts
well damn all right yeah but that was my
only ever paranoia or run yeah with cops
but never that's never really been like
a a fear of mine no off the acid and
[ __ ] so but you guys are pranks I
remember you said you just pranked the
show of each other yeah dude what about
we were boys man why don't you prank
your uncles
oh for the show
it's family I mean we could I would love
to get the brothers on there yeah dude
well listen we'll do a bunch of
different things the whole idea of it
being called family tussle
is it could be anybody's family it could
be you versus him
you're saying it crosses over them yeah
yeah Patriots fans or whatever [ __ ] it
could be anybody yep yeah and and it's
very specific to your
what you're what you want to compete
against each other with like if your two
families wanted to compete well how
would you compete
I have no [ __ ] idea right but that's
not it but you know what I'm saying
you're too high to speak I am so [ __ ]
up I'm putting out the whole thing at
once yeah one episode at a time so then
how long till episode 2. a week
damn you're rolling it out over here is
that how it works
yeah that's the longest drink
I've ever heard I think it's every week
is what it is it's every week up until
because I was thinking about when the
break's gonna be I think it's every week
up until
Thanksgiving and then we're taking like
a Hiatus a little bit of a break and
then we'll release the other half how
long did it take to film all of it
a week is it a full week oh you guys
were working hard that's five days
that wasn't the only thing you filmed in
that day then you guys were filming all
day oh we filmed we did 10 episodes dude
yeah holy [ __ ] we did I think what the
schedule was
three in a day
and then
three in a day
and then like punishments and b-roll
right or like the last two days and
there was like another episode that we
filmed that I'm not gonna air
so Nine episodes total that we will Air
punishments get pretty intense from
oh damn punishments are uh
pretty pretty intense like you saw
yeah like uh yeah if like for you saw
that and then the ones for me are uh the
ones for me are
I don't want to say anything that gives
anything away
um
definitely less painful in the physical
form oh my God less so so that's that's
all about because like that's what you
know those are the those are the two
things that we definitely I can't ever
embarrass him
but he can try for me and I know for me
that I'll physically can't embarrass
this man
okay embarrass me it's impossible he
embarrassed us him every every weekend
on stage look at me right now yeah have
you ever been genuinely so high
how many people you almost just ate that
microphone
I do I mean we're over here having a
side I am so [ __ ] up this is
ridiculous I cannot believe I'm like 10
minutes behind you
I will tell you that a wave of something
just hit right here
oh no I'm like What's Up
I'm high for sure
oh closing your eyes on these ones
patterns are going crazy yeah it is that
convertible is gonna be awesome on the
drive back for you
oh I'm starting to get super hot I'm
[ __ ] up dude
they keep going they got they got so
much stronger I feel yeah yeah well you
did take no I got one I'm just like yeah
I mean I'm high now man
I mean I was high before but I'm pretty
high now yeah oh [ __ ] I mean you know
what happens when you talk [ __ ] to drugs
though and you're like I'm not feeling
it yet like I don't think it's really
hidden they're gonna punch you squaring
them out what happened you know what I'm
saying like that's that's just what
happened when you talk [ __ ] about drugs
like
what
when you talk [ __ ] about drugs they
listen they listen
hey man podcast also right yeah we've
been doing that we've been trying to get
on it uh every week but his he's got a
crazy schedule he just did like a uh uh
a road a road tour where he was in New
Mexico for two nights and then he was in
Dallas but he was driving with his
opener Sandy Danto
um who we [ __ ] love and we'll be in
Portland with us this weekend
um and they just drove from uh LA to New
Mexico to Dallas to you know they just
did their own thing how am I doing
from a distance how does it look does it
look like I'm keeping it together or
oh yeah yeah
perfect that there's never been more
fitting [ __ ] jacket
it's perfect yeah yeah I'm just trying
to I'm I'm trying to figure out how long
how long it's gonna take me to get my
[ __ ] together oh me too I kept looking
down like what holy [ __ ] I've gone like
this still this how exactly what I just
said to myself [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] guys
mushrooms don't last 40 minutes it's not
that I can control my [ __ ] and go hey
calm down [ __ ] and I it's not
it's not pretty high oh it's not at all
these ones are not the same excited
yeah but so he's he's been busy but you
know we've been we've been banging out
podcasts um as much as we can
um but it's always you know a really
good time it's just you know a day a
week that we get together for a little
over an hour he can't ever figure out
how to upgrade his Zoom so that's a
pretty funny joke every time we get on
um I've paid for that
[ __ ] upgrade like probably 37
times however many no joke Marty how
however many episodes we've done that's
how many times I've paid for that
[ __ ] oh I feel you upgrade that
[ __ ] God damn would you say
upgrade what do you mean
I don't know
oh
my God what the [ __ ]
Jesus Christ that's how I feel every
time I do something online
I don't even know my mother [ __ ] tell
you what the deal is with that
[ __ ] but there it is
God
I have no idea what you just asked me
I forgot what the question was I really
don't even know the most passionate
response of all time what you just asked
me so it was about the zoom upgrade but
don't go on a rant again oh yeah yeah
whatever I don't remember yeah yeah no
big deal but uh so that's always fun uh
I mean we're trying to get that the zoom
yeah yeah but you know that's I mean
that's that's a joke
yeah
I got it I understood that I'm tripping
a different language right now Maybe
might have been gibberish it was
gibberish yeah yeah I thought I was
tripping I was like is he speaking
English right now I think I've been
speaking English yeah it was just yeah
he had a lot of words he had a lot of
words close together no no because he
was understood I got you I got you it
was understood but I definitely was
speaking Yeah Yeah
100 the English not the Spanish the
English the English
these mushrooms are so strong I didn't
realize there was gonna be this [ __ ]
strong yeah yeah I you know you I
remember how I said how do you take
mushrooms like you're on a show and yeah
last few times I've taken them oh [ __ ]
no
hell no I should be in a dark room by
myself right now oh you want to end it
is that it no I'm staying the [ __ ]
feeling of this is like this it's
different
yo these are [ __ ]
ing [ __ ] I can't wait when you close
close your eyes for a second I got the
craziest [ __ ] visuals When I close my
eyes oh when I put my eyes down like
this it got insane that's when I went
[ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah I don't know Don't Close Your
Eyes you're not gonna be talking I
couldn't tell you what I've been doing
this episode it's hard for me to say
what it's like when I close my eyes
you've been doing great all right just
making sure I couldn't tell you how long
we've been here man I mean for real like
you're my judge yeah you're doing great
all right perfect you're you're still on
track and still you know you're human
and when you're not talking is when I
get worried like when you're on like
when you're up a little bit like of
course you're gonna talk a lot but you
and I both talk a lot when we're sober
so okay that's pretty fair so you know
it it's just when you when you don't
talk is when I'm like oh something's
wrong but
yeah nothing's wrong okay because you're
just having a good time I just don't
want you to go too overboard with the
mushrooms because
I know you've got [ __ ] to do tomorrow
okay hey guess what I am 100 done oh me
too yeah yeah I got to the point about
20 minutes ago I went I regret this why
I regret this I regret that second
character oh [ __ ]
I looked over Marty and went Marty's
goddess he went so the show went thank
God Mary's here because I'm I'm gone we
were having a side conversation yeah
Marty and I were just you know talking
about [ __ ] in the other side of the room
essentially I thought we were so far
when you did that oh they're right there
they're right here yeah hey man
I felt like we were on the other side of
the [ __ ] planet right now
okay let's
play that game that's what game how long
it's been since we started me and you
should try this wait I want to play okay
but you're you're 108
did you look are you no I'm just
guessing I'm just well don't look now
it's not there yet oh okay but I'm gonna
say one away oh no
yes oh that's when you're oh it's oh
don't don't do the yawns of the
mushrooms I feel like it's when it
starts to go yeah it starts to get worse
for me me too damn it yo we're feeling
the same thing because I feel it coming
too yeah well I love uh [ __ ] wait so
we're playing the game so he gets an
hour and eight minutes I'm gonna say
it's an hour and eight minutes you I
don't even remember what we're guessing
you're guessing how long we've been here
[ __ ]
now how long we've been here been here
but how long we've been
here oh no on the show Bingo It's gotta
be an hour it's definitely been at least
100 an hour I say our oh [ __ ] we've been
here for a minute hour 27 minutes I'm
going hour 15 hour 14 hour 27. I'm going
hour 15 answers I'll answer our hour 27
hour 15. oh we're 19. oh wow what'd you
say hour 15. Price is Right rules I win
Price is Right rules it's it's true you
win Price is Right rules always final
showdown M showcase showdown and
you were all so closer
yes also it even if you were yeah yes
yeah correct yeah you're also way close
by a couple not by like how crazy amount
but like a couple okay I can't believe
you're doing the math right now I would
try
you got it you know I got that sure
he's actually he's actually a mental
math wizard I'm not gonna see it I'm not
gonna get another planet and do some
[ __ ] long division I could I could
tell
a long division not attitude I don't
think so
what
why did you whisper that The Whispers
comedy dude for comedy
what the [ __ ] with towels if I said
short
that's the jacket that makes that [ __ ]
look mysterious
so [ __ ] ridiculous though these ones
are very like
oh I feel like like almost like when I
used to take a lot of [ __ ] masculine
feel like I'm a melt into this [ __ ]
table that yo this episode's turned into
me just being on drugs eternally in my
head listening to you guys talk I don't
even remember if I talked to that I'm
[ __ ] up you're doing great you're
driving
for sure Rosie's driving home hey
I want to make sure that what I said for
comedy that that didn't hurt your
feelings no nothing there's nothing you
could really say that hurts my feelings
I'm super in my own feelings right now
because that's how much mushrooms have
happened
absolutely not okay I don't think
there's anything now at this point in
time in our career together because you
could say you know what I'm saying like
there's nothing really you could say
that could hurt my feelings at this
point that's the last thing I remember
before I got [ __ ] up was the story
what does that mean you mean just
because of all of the stories yeah for
like comedy like I know what's the
difference between like what's serious
and what's right right I have that
ability to filter what's not okay guys
right in life more than most people oh
yeah without a doubt like I I you know
I have recently been aware of some
[ __ ] that he takes
like it's been some sort of privilege
yo to have millions of people
laugh at stories about you growing up
like the balls it takes just to be him I
can't I've noticed some of the comments
sometimes
yeah dude like the just the skin you
must have man oh yeah no no no I really
I
yeah the skin you must have is pretty
crazy yeah it's definitely not thin
that's for sure yeah I did and I I this
is not this is not like um
this is the first time I've thought of
it it's not something like
yeah he must have just a crazy gist
whatever the [ __ ] you want to say about
me mentality yeah yeah absolutely like
what what else I want that for my kids
though that it's like really like I care
what people think but at the end of the
day it's really can't change how I feel
about myself 100 but like for me what it
also has become is like look you can
care what people think but you have to
be able to like divide you don't have to
care what people you don't people you
don't know or people who aren't like
valid or relevant in your life like you
don't have to listen to anything they
have to say people are just trolls on
the internet and sound but I'm obviously
like are you I'm sorry I'm sorry you had
to yet
I'm not sorry you had to learn that I'm
sorry you had to learn it at such a
young age
I think it benefits me I I would say
honestly I wouldn't accept the sorry I
would more just say thank you because
like even if you're not looking at it as
something that's like positive in the
moment it has made my life positive and
it's made me more positive because it's
given me the courage to say who gives a
[ __ ] do you know what I'm saying so like
it helped early on I mean like I got
picked on a lot and like growing up as
well just like in school so that also
built up skin a little bit but then once
I like got into this world a little more
and like became a little more present
with him and my family and finding out
you know
what comedy really was and figuring out
that these people go on stage and some
people have to go on stage in order to
get started to just go out there and
bomb but you
you can't stop you can't let other
people's thoughts affect you the only
way to get better is to keep doing it
and keep trying and just
brush it off
so that's what I started doing and then
that's when my life started to change
and who I was started to change and so
that was beneficial to me so I wouldn't
say uh yeah so
I've never heard you say that before
yeah I wouldn't say I wouldn't say sorry
from your point and I wouldn't say like
I don't think it was your plan but no it
is what happened and we can't change
what happened it is what it is but I
would definitely say it benefit the way
that I developed as a human and also
like I feel like you coming up might
have been your generation way more
innocent than your generation of kids
and even the kids younger than you are
so mean like and so detached
keyboard keyboard Warriors
it's almost like by the time that you're
19 20 now you're on YouTube like
you've been having people say horrible
[ __ ] crazy just by virtue of being a kid
I don't know why I haven't thought about
that because like Rocco too I talked to
tell stories from my little brother
think about that either
craziest thing that things that people
say to children like y'all got a lot of
time on your hands like what's what's
the deal there's other kids too yeah
this is what you do on your free time
though like like and look man
part of it I have to shoulder
heart of the blame
for mate putting it in public Arena yeah
right right so I have to
no no I can't absolve myself of this
like I can't but it just comes with it
he's saying he knows what he signed up
for with us because you did ask me
before you put the stuff out for sure so
like he's right like I do know what I
signed up for you I mean like I get but
to say it to the things that people
would it's just crazy yeah but it's not
anytime there's more than a couple
hundred thousand people you're gonna get
some evil [ __ ] people are saying it's
just normal I get evil [ __ ] just like we
get evil [ __ ] all the time oh yeah like
you get evil [ __ ] just from people you
think you know you know what I'm saying
so like it is what it is yeah but like
a lot of the evil stuff I read sometime
I have read about
you is lucky the it was some sort of
privilege
to have your business in the street like
that
there's no privilege I don't know it's
public yeah having having my having my
stories and mistakes and a lot a lot of
mistakes public is definitely not a
privilege but I definitely understand
why he says that because when he's when
I think about that it's like
I mean if it didn't happen like life
would be different but privilege is not
the right word I would more use the word
opportunity
because you know you can you can go two
ways with it you can even take it and
run with it like I did or you can turn
your back on it and just be scared and
you're also like really working behind
the scenes yeah 100 well I mean I'm more
than a story and that's what I'm
creating right now but there's but
there's no doubt look see
my my point is like this when I say
people think it's the privileging is
like
there's just two there's two sides
there's two sides to
everything from the outside it looks
like everything is [ __ ] phenomenal
do you know what else he makes and I
don't think I've ever said this to you
man
yo dude
no I'm not gonna say that ah come on you
can't build me up like that I'll I'll do
it off the air though okay all right all
right fair enough I left everybody on a
cliffhanger though yeah
but that's not something for a podcast
okay but I'm a [ __ ] grown-up
fair enough you know what I'm saying
yeah absolutely
so [ __ ] up
I feel like you oh I'm pretty bad no
like when you're usually on this show oh
yeah yeah
am I keeping it together pretty good
yeah I think I thought that was a good
moment right there yeah I think you're
doing great
um you guys look [ __ ] up back there
hey y'all by the way yeah that's who
actually they're asking am I keeping it
am I how am I doing okay
right now yeah I would just I'm just
watching yeah I'm the shortest
[ __ ] at this table so I'm just
like I'm down here what's up family
tussle that's what's up yeah facts well
listen oh no I might tell you something
right now yeah this you've got you guys
so you watched it before it's the best
thing I've ever done I'm so proud to
work with you dude it was so much fun
I'm so proud of the person you've become
like you are [ __ ] you're the real
deal I appreciate it yeah I love you I
love you too I was excited for this show
it's so worse we're both super excited
everyone had mushrooms before
well it's going to bring up your day
it's you got holidays coming up right
yeah you had a blessed day so many days
like Preposterous amount of days he's
got like in the month well where am I
this weekend wait when is this coming up
Monday
Monday what day is it right now
what day is Tuesday Monday Tuesday
Portland you got Omaha Boston yeah
you off for the rest of the year after
November oh you're you're December we're
going we're also doing uh Tempe Arizona
improv uh for New Year's and for the
couple days leading up to oh thanks
um
well good good timing perfect
I cannot [ __ ] believe this episode I
couldn't tell you what we talked about I
have no idea what we talked about at all
I'm I'm do you want me to do the advice
give me the address yeah let's go [ __ ]
I've never felt like this
hit me especially oh it's a different
feeling I hate it you gotta look them up
yeah let me know we do them after we do
them after so it's fine we have to reset
us reset and all that [ __ ]
seems like a tomorrow thing no no Mario
lives too far it has to be done today oh
God
she seems like it may be in a couple
hours
just show me this [ __ ] screen
and I'll do the address he has the
opposite energy right now I'm like that
oh my God I need a [ __ ] box and this
guy show me some [ __ ] address oh
thank God it just snapped me out a
little bit there we go I'm back thank
God I was not having a great trip for a
minute and we're back how you guys doing
this is a podcast and we're back hi
welcome welcome what's up man we're back
to Earth
holy [ __ ] the past 20 minutes
we're all [ __ ] that [ __ ]
what's been going on I was I was gone
stuck don't even remember we were
talking about I'm back now [ __ ] wow good
evening
these ones oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] those are
strong I was gone you're back I'm back
we're having it we're on we're we're
filming yeah yeah what's up guys we're
trying to do ad reads for you yeah I
mean you do you wanna I'm no I'm back
now I just I can't believe how strong
this was you do this all the time and
you're on your lives you're um
yeah you are a monster I cannot do this
I I was gone I couldn't even tell you
what I [ __ ] said
I don't know what I said in two year old
I'll give me some adread I mean that
sparked me back like yeah [ __ ] yes wake
up and then like I can do an ad read why
not yeah
by the way did we talk about stuff oh
yeah we need to talk about yeah a lot of
stuff
you just said I think we hit everything
yeah I think we hit everything and then
some but also I don't think we hit oh we
had a couple this whole side of the
table is [ __ ] intoxicated yeah and I
feel like you guys could have kept it
together I don't even know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about we talked about
you know the things oh yeah oh okay cool
and then we brought you guys into
talking also about the things I was
having some crazy visuals when I closed
my eyes yeah you kept saying that every
time I kept looking at you when you were
talking I swear to God you've seen
Aladdin you had the Jafar [ __ ] on I'm
like Dan Jake was like Jafar and I was
closing my eyes like this is evil is
what's going on and I started getting my
little dark spot [ __ ]
I feel you so sorry that happened I'm so
happy I'm back I'm sorry I haven't had a
bad trip and I'm so so good once I was
16.
can I ask you a question about somebody
who is sitting right next to you
how would I have woken you up from that
like you looked like you were just kind
of I was fine I was doing that get out
[ __ ] where I was like I'm stuck can't
[ __ ] get out of it that's how I felt
but I'm back to [ __ ] get out [ __ ]
it's like sleep paralysis
are we good we're good wow I haven't had
[ __ ] mushrooms do that's mean
yeah we're back man we're back
the walls are breathing though that's
why that's what I want to see and walls
walls are breathing oh they're moving
all the paint's just doing yeah the
paint has been dancing all night this
room is this room is
like
psychedelics but that's when I was
asking you if the table was moving I I
got what you meant yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's understandable and then my little I
get like the leg trembles My legs will
do this like I'm from the inside and
it's been doing like 20 minutes I
thought that was no they're about to hit
harder yeah
oh they're coming but like in a good way
I'm happy I'm stoked now we're this is
good it's good
adults in the room you talked about the
good [ __ ] we were supposed to talk about
can I can I tell you
I
um
sometimes I drift off
with mushrooms there's no doubt like
look we've been together when you're the
one you've been the adult in the room
yeah I mean so it's very rare
right every other time
that we've been together and the only
good thing is like right here Rose is
right there I can see the blue so I know
I've been fine this whole time yeah dude
so I know I'm good it's just there's a
few time like dude we're on camera but
there's there's you know what we're
talking about dude I'm trying to host
this [ __ ] these particular
um caramels
it's so so quickly
I don't know what's in them I don't yeah
and I don't know if I'm like I said I
don't know if I'm supposed to give away
the guy's name or something Jesus Christ
yo do us a favor yeah let's wrap it up a
little bit
you talked about your dates
everything podcast amen podcast we got
family tussle out now I'm all on just
Josh Wolf on YouTube face YouTube and
Facebook right yeah yeah yeah we have
family tussle that's out right now on
YouTube and Facebook the first episode
is out
um I feel like that's why I kept asking
when is this yeah I feel you right now
I'm like what day is it when is this
when is this coming out Monday Monday so
it'll already be out okay so it's it's
Tuesday the week before so I feel like
we talked about this already we did I
gave you I gave you that answered by the
time this comes out
by the time this comes out family title
episode one will be out on YouTube and
Facebook Josh Wolf comedy go find it
um the second episode should be coming
out pretty shortly also after this
podcast release I think our second
episode will be dropping the day after
or if not the two days after
um
his [ __ ] together
um comedian Josh wolf.com for tour dates
and tickets
um the YouTube uh uh uh Jake understood
yeah have a dope ass day you know what
the [ __ ] deal is this is a great time
thank you having us again man
um this was another interesting one it
wasn't as long as the first the last one
we did but it was definitely jam-packed
with some [ __ ] so thank you again yeah
what the [ __ ] just happened thank you
again for having us thanks guys and we
can't wait uh we can't wait to come back
right what what did this happen you
should get headphones off and I went are
we done is it over and then you're
missing a rabbit I'm like that was a
perfect wrap up I think I got you [ __ ]
is it is that it are we good hey
[Music]
[Music]
perfect